qué es una fuerza conservativa las
fuerzas conservativa son aquellas
fuerzas en las cuales el trabajo
realizado por estas sobre un objeto sólo
dependen de la posición inicial y la
posición final del objeto en otras
palabras el trabajo realizado por una
fuerza conservativa sobre una masa no va
a depender de la ruta que tome esa masa
si el trabajo realizado por una fuerza
sigue esta regla podemos llamarla una
fuerza conservativa por ejemplo la
fuerza gravitacional en una masa de 5
kilogramos es de 49 newtons si la masa
se mueve hacia abajo unos 6 metros el
trabajo realizado por la fuerza de
gravedad va a ser de 294 jules ahora
comencemos de nuevo digamos que de nuevo
esta masa se mueve hacia abajo 6 metros
pero después se mueve hacia arriba 6
metros y después de nuevo hacia abajo 6
metros el trabajo realizado por la
gravedad para el primer viaje hacia
abajo
294 jules y después para el viaje hacia
arriba ya que la fuerza de gravedad está
apuntando en la dirección opuesta al
movimiento de la masa el trabajo
realizado por la gravedad es de menos
294 jules finalmente para el último
viaje hacia abajo el trabajo es
nuevamente 294 jules positivos lo que
significa que el trabajo total realizado
en esta masa debido a la gravedad sigue
siendo 294 jules positivos igual que
cuando la masa se desplazó hacia abajo 6
metros sólo una vez en otras palabras el
trabajo realizado por la fuerza
gravitacional no depende de los detalles
del camino recorrido por la masa sólo
depende de la posición inicial y la
posición final de esta masa de hecho
podríamos dejar que la masa tomara
cualquier ruta desde esta posición
inicial hasta la posición final y el
trabajo hecho por la gravedad seguiría
siendo de 294 euros
y ya que el trabajo realizado por la
gravedad no depende de la ruta que sigue
el objeto decimos que la fuerza de
gravedad es una fuerza conservativa la
fuerza ejercida por un resorte es otro
ejemplo de una fuerza conservativa el
trabajo realizado sobre una masa por un
resorte no depende de la ruta tomada por
la masa sólo depende de su posición
inicial y su posición final el término
conservativa viene del hecho de que las
fuerzas conservativa se conservan
energía mecánica a diferencia de las
fuerzas no conserva tibás que no
conservan energía mecánica la energía
mecánica es la energía cinética más la
energía potencial gravitatoria más la
energía potencial del resorte un ejemplo
de una fuerza no conservativa es la
fricción si yo muevo una masa sobre una
mesa desde el punto a hasta el punto b
la fricción va a realizar cierta
cantidad de trabajo negativo sobre esta
masa lo que va a crear
algo de energía térmica si en lugar de
ir directo desde el punto a hasta el
punto b hago que esta masa vaya desde el
punto a hasta el punto b una y otra y
otra vez el trabajo realizado por la
fricción se va a volver cada vez más
grande y va a generar cada vez más
energía térmica y ya que el trabajo
realizado por la fricción depende de la
ruta tomada la fricción no es una fuerza
conservativa de forma similar la
resistencia al aire tampoco es una
fuerza conservativa ya que el trabajo
realizado por la resistencia al aire
depende del detalle de la ruta tomada
eso es saber que si una fuerza es
conservativa podemos definir una energía
potencial para esa fuerza es por eso que
las fuerzas conservativa como la
gravedad o la fuerza del resorte tienen
energías potenciales asociadas a ellas y
fuerzas no conserva tibás como la
fricción no tienen energías potenciales
asociadas esto tiene sentido porque si
realizamos trabajo opuesto a la fuerza
gravitacional
dar una masa en el aire podemos tener de
vuelta esa energía al dejar que la masa
caiga convirtiendo energía potencial en
energía cinética de forma similar si
realizamos trabajo en contra de la
fuerza de un resorte al comprimir un
resorte usando una masa podremos tener
esa energía de regreso al dejar que el
resorte se descomprima lo que hace que
la energía potencial almacenada se
transforme en energía cinética pero si
realizamos trabajo en contra de la
fuerza de fricción nos va a ser muy
difícil tratar de recuperar esa energía
ya que la energía se ha disipado en
forma de energía térmica y ahora se
encuentra distribuida aleatoriamente en
la superficie y en la masa